This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Skillshare, home to 15,000 classes
that could teach you a new life skill. The
first 400 people to sign up using the link
the description will get a 2 month free trial.
Since it’s birth in 1950 the cars of the
formula 1 racing championship have continually
got faster. Superior aerodynamics, more powerful
engines and lighter materials have all contributed
to make track times plummet. The average speed
for the Monaco Grand Prix rose from 104 km/h
in 1950 to 170 in 2007, but something strange
happened in 2007. They stopped getting faster,,
not only that, they got slower. So what happened
and what have the FIA done in 2017 to breath
some life into the championship again?
In the past decade there has been a massive
shift in focus for the F1 championship. The
sky-rocketing cost of competing forced the
FIA to bring in rules to even the playing
field and prevent better funded teams from
bullying other teams out of the competition.
This change in attitude is earmarked by the
2007 engine development freeze and the cost
saving measures continued as Honda, BMW and
Toyota were forced to withdraw from the championship
following the 2008 world economic crisis.
Newer rules have put tire saving and fuel
efficiency at the forefront of design, which
has also forced drivers to be more conservative
on the tracks,forcing the track times down.
Whether it is because of these changes or
not, Formula 1’s popularity has been declining
and we need to remember that Formula 1 is
itself a business. A business that has to
keep both the companies racing AND the fans
happy.
So this year’s rule changes are focused
on making the sport faster and more dramatic,
in the hopes of putting a stop to Formula
1’s declining popularity.
So what changes have been made and how do
they affect the car's performance? The most
noticeable change to this year's Formula 1
cars is the overall width of the car. The
width of this years cars has increased from
1800 mm to 2000 mm. with a significant amount
of this additional width being allocated to
facilitating wider tyres. This dramatically
increases the contact area of the tyres to
the ground, which increases the traction the
tyre has.
Now, if you look at the equations for friction,
you will see it is independent of area. Friction
is simply given as the coefficient of friction
multiplied b y the weight of the car. So how
does a wider tyre increase traction? A wider
contact area does affect the wear on the tyre,
meaning a narrower tyre will lose it’s grip
material quicker. To counteract that the tyre
needs to be made of a harder material that
won’t wear as quickly. F1 teams have 5 dry
weather materials to chose from during races,
ranging from ultrasoft to hard. The softer
materials have higher coefficient of frictions,
but don’t last very long. So in essence,
the wider tyres have allowed the softer higher
grip tyres to last longer. Allowing drivers
to brake later and accelerate harder.
These wider tyres needed a wider front wing,
as it’s primary purpose is not to generate
downforce, but to manipulate the incoming
air to flow around the tires. The tyres can
generate a great deal of drag and also generate
a huge amount of turbulent air, which would
prevent the aerodynamic surfaces downstream
of the tyre from working correctly, so the
front wing is designed to direct the air to
flow around the tyre.
One of the most beautiful applications of
this air flow management is this vortex, named
the Y250 vortex. By F1 rules this central
portion of the front wing is not allowed to
generate any downforce, but 250 mm from the
centre you may.The vortex is a result of downforce
being generated by the front wing, BUT instead
of just being a negative side-effect that
causes drag vortices have been carefully crafted
to bend the air away from the tyres and to
where it is needed .
To learn more let’s look at some engineering
simulations and compare the differences between
the 2016 and 2017 cars. These may look scary
to an untrained eye, but here’s the gist
of what you need to know. Here we are looking
at the air pressure along the car, with the
position being indicated here. Blue and green
is low pressure air, yellow and red is higher
pressure air. An F1 car wants low pressure
air below the car and high pressure air above
the car, as that is what generates downforce.
Let’s bring this simulation back to the
start and see how these changes have affected
the performance of the car. Here you can see
the Y250 vortex beginning to form as air rolls
from the upper surface of the wing to the
lower surface. You can clearly see that the
Y250 vortex is larger this year as a result
of the larger wing surface and it gets larger
as it travels down the vehicle, as the low
pressure vortex sucks in the surrounding air
and the more air it consumes, the less air
can get under the car, thus dropping the air
pressure. You can see this happening here
as the floor structure begins.
You can also see the Y250 vortex begins to
generate additional low pressure vortices
this year off the bargeboard, which steers
the vortices and helps them generate new low
pressure vortices like this one being formed
off this neat little aerofoil.
The bargeboard was not allowed last year in
this location, as this area was an exclusion
zone, which is an area where structures are
not allowed to be placed. Teams like Mercedes
have incredibly intricate bargeboards, much
more complicated than the ones in this model.
Travelling further we can see the 2017 version
is noticeably greener here, and thus is lower
pressure, this combined with the wider floor,
allows the 2017 car to generate much more
downforce.
.
Travelling further again we find the primary
cause of this drop in pressure, the diffuser,
this part at the back of the car, which has
increased in height and width. The diffuser
is essentially the exit nozzle for the air
underneath the car, and by having a larger
opening the air exiting from underneath the
car is forced to expand and accelerate to
fill the space, this causes the air pressure
to drop even further, as Bernoulli's principle
tells us that an increase in the velocity
of a fluid corresponds with a decrease in
air pressure.
The diffuser provides a huge amount of downforce,
with very little drag. The same can’t be
said for the rear wing, which was placed high
above the car in 2016, creating a lot of additional
drag. The rear wing has dropped down in 2017,
reducing its effect on drag as it’s placed
in the air that has already been affected
by the structures upstream. This was an effort
to maintain the top speed of the car, as drag
has increased dramatically with the widening
of the car. The teams have been provided an
additional 5 kilograms of fuel to counteract
this also.
As we are half-way through the 2017 season,
we are able to see the effects these changes
have made on F1. Without a doubt we have some
of the best looking cars F1 have seen in a
long time, and they are breaking records again,
thanks to the additional traction provided
by the wider wheels and superior aerodynamics.
But this additional speed in corners had to
sacrifice some of the exciting overtaking
action, as the wider cars are generating a
great deal more dirty air behind them, making
it difficult for followings cars get enough
downforce in corners. So have these changes
made F1 more exciting to watch? I’ll leave
that to you to decide.
Many of you ask me what software I use to
animate these videos and how I learned. In
today’s video I used a combination of Adobe
After Effects and SimScale and taught myself
how to use both by watching videos online.
These days you can teach yourself pretty much
any skill online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it. With professional and understandable
classes, that follow a clear learning curve
Skillshare is an online learning community
for creators with more than 15,000 classes
in graphic design, animation, web development,
music, photography, video game design and
more. Unfortunately, there are no engineering
simulations classes there yet, but I am working
on creating my own for Skillshare at this
very moment.
A Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses, but the
first 500 people to sign up with this link
will get a 2 month free trial. In those 2
months you could easily learn the skills you
need to start a new hobby or business, just
like I did with this channel. So ask yourself
right now. What skill have you been putting
off learning. What project have you been dreaming
of completing, but you aren’t sure if you
have the skills to do it. Why not start right
now and sign up to Skillshare using the link
below. You have nothing to lose and a valuable
life skill to gain.
As usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my Patreon supporters. I just uploaded
a new episode of Showmakers, my podcast with
Sam from Wendover Productions with special
guests from the Wisecrack channel. The link
to thank, and likes to my twitter, facebook
and instagram pages are below.